for coming in today.
Uh, group therapy, I know it can
make men a little uncomfortable.
But I guarantee you
your communication
skills will improve.
Well, why don't we
start with you, David.
Um, okay.
So I know Lisa--
that's my wife.
Um... she thinks we just
hit a bump in our marriage
but the thing
is, um...
for the last
few years
I've had a secret
family in Tampa.
It sounds bad.
David, there are
no judgments here.
That must be
very painful
for you to have
a secret from your wife.
It's the worst.
Have you given any
thought to a remedy?
Well, yeah, I was
thinking, um...
maybe going on a sunset boat
ride for our anniversary?
Take her out in
the open ocean,
drug her,
throw her in the
water so she drowns.
Okay, okay,
okay, okay.
How do we-- uh, what do--
how 'bout we say for now
that you do nothing?
Well, it's not for
a couple months.
Okay, good, so...
So don't do anything--
do nothing.
Uh, and, uh, Ben.
Do you have a share?
My deal is a few months
ago I told my wife
I was going on
a business trip.
But in truth,
I went on a two-month sex
tour of sub-Sahara Africa.
So that.
How do you feel?
How do you feel about
that, how do you feel?
Honestly... great.
That was the best trip I ever
took in my life, hands down.
If you ever get
the chance to go...
Really?
Go.
Is it expensive?
Yeah, it's crazy
expensive...
Okay, okay, well,
that'll be interesting
for us to research
on our own.
Oh, yeah, all right, so,
as a result of
my trip now
I'm in a ton of debt.
I'm hiding it
from Karen
and I just don't even know
how to bring it up to her.
That's a difficult
conversation to have.
Maybe we could
all brainstorm
some solutions
together.
Oh, well, I was kinda more
thinking, you know,
probably just chop her
up in little pieces
and drain her
bank account.
Okay, uh, you
know what,
I wanna just pause
here, uh...
Um, first of all,
no one feel any pressure to
unload everything... today.
It's the first day.
And then also, um, maybe
as a group we can...
we can come up
with, uh...
with a solution
to Ben's issues
that don't involve
him murdering Karen.
Um... he can hire
somebody to kill Karen?
Oh.
Great, okay.
I didn't even
think of that.
Um, you know what--
how about...
Let's all work
together here
and come up with
some solutions,
uh... where we
can keep Karen
alive.
Alive...
Alive.
Oh, what if
I bury her alive?
Okay, that-- no.
Just kind of like
meeting halfway.
At the end of that,
she would still be dead.
Sebastian...
Sebastian, we haven't
heard from you, yet.
So, I've been playing
fantasy football
with this same group of
guys for years now.
But, uh, my wife,
Darflin, she nags me
for spending so
much time on it.
I just wish she could
understand that that's just
time I'm using to
like zone out.
Have you tried
expressing to your wife
that's just time that you
need to decompress?
I don't know.
But, and the other
part of it is
last weekend I fucked all the
guys in the fantasy league
and I never used
any protection
like... at all.
And... we did
everything.
Um, you are, uh,
I think you're putting
Darfla's health
at stake.
It's Darflin.
Darflin's health
at stake.
You're kind of obligated
to tell her.
I know that on paper, that--
that's the right thing to do
but you just have no idea
how high-strung she is.
I really think the
best thing to do
is just sneak up behind
her and break her neck.
Okay, okay.
Is it really easier
to kill her
than it would be
to just talk to her?
Yeah.
Well, yeah, 'cause
I think, if I, if I,
if I told her it would
probably kill her anyway.
Babe, are you
ready or what?
I told you 8:00.
Yeah, but I'm
hungry now.
Ten minutes.
Can't we just
wrap it up?
Go to the car.
How much longer
can these guys
talk about
their feelings.
Get in the
fucking car.
Let's go.
You get in the car.
Chop, chop,
come on.
Close the door.
( door shuts )
I'm so sorry about
that everyone.
Sometimes, I don't
know what to do.
Well, you could slowly poison
him over time or something.
Yeah, it'll just look
like he got sick.
Yeah.
Or-- off of what
David just said,
uh, you go on a
hiking trip, right?
Then when he
falls asleep,
you shoot him
with a gun
that you got off
the Mexican internet.
They have their
own internet?
Yeah, it's mostly
just for guns.
But, uh... it's
untraceable.
It's not hard, I got the
number if you want it.
Yeah, I'd love
the number.